Nobody really is in a position to
guess how big a computer you need,
or a bigger,
faster computers and you need to do
the highest levels of human thought.
And I suspect it's rather small and
that each bit of what a computer does
probably needs thousands of neurons.
And so most of the brain is
because neurons are rather
unreliable and noisy and
flaky. We need a lot of them, but
they're not computing very much.
Interesting. So, so, uh,
Alpha go played this move,
which I want to hear more about in a
second, but, uh, Lee has left the room.
He left the room after room
after that move. Huh? I mean,
I'm not even going to ask me. It's a
very surprising, it's a surprising move.
I wasn't expecting that.